we're going to read just
a couple of short sections from the end
of parenthood and relationship which is
chapter 8 of
hunter gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
um having just so the section
immediately proceeding is a fairly
um a fairly in-depth and
discussion of senescence and
um and and how our children provide us
immortality of sorts
which is fairly fairly deep and serious
section so love across species
in pursuing lighter fare than
considering that children not
immortality are the antidote to aging
let us ask we love our pets but do they
love
us
humans have domesticated dozens of
species of animals across the globe
mostly to provide food or do labor for
us some of those relationships that
began as purely functional
cats as mousers dogs as protection have
since become cross species friendships
cats have befriended us for far less
time and remain more wild than dogs
more of their original selves although
they bond tightly to humans under the
right circumstances
even before we began to farm though dogs
were by many of our sides becoming
domesticated
as hunter-gatherers some of us already
had dog friends
dogs are in many way a human construct
we have co-evolved with them for so long
that they are now attuned to human
behavior
language and emotion perhaps you could
argue then
that humans are also partially a canine
construct
does your pet love you of course your
pet loves you
qualifier your pet can love you if it's
a mammal or one of a few clades of birds
like a parrot if your pet is a gecko or
a python or a goldfish
your pet is probably incapable of love
love develops for every evolutionary
pairing that requires devotion
we love our pets and our pets love us
dogs in particular are love generators
who hang out with you and help you know
that you're not alone
dog is love unmoored
watch how cats and dogs engage with each
other and with us they don't use
language to convey meaning and emotion
but convey it they do
you have no reason to doubt that your
dog is disappointed when you stop
throwing the ball for him
or that your cat would prefer that you
stay seated with her in your lap
we name our emotions love fear grief
and when we attribute those words to
animals we may be accused of
anthropomorphizing
as franz duvall who has spent a lifetime
studying emotion and animals points out
this argument is rooted in assumptions
of humans being not just exceptional
but wholly different from the other
animals with which we share ancestors
we need to be careful in how we
attribute emotion and attention to other
animals
as we should within our own species as
well but there can be no doubt that many
other species plan and grieve
love and reflect in our interactions
with our pets we read their cues without
language
it is helpful too in your interactions
with people to turn the sound down
sometimes
be an animal behaviorist or just act
sometimes like a human before language
evolved
we often use language to cover how we
actually feel to deceive
to throw off the scent of what is
actually going on when you watch people
especially strangers from a distance
it's relatively easy to read the emotion
of the situation
pay attention to people's behavior not
the stories that people tell about their
behavior
that's what your dog is doing your dog
doesn't buy your cover story
although he is likely to forgive you for
your foibles
next section grief in his metamorphoses
avid writes of the old married couple
bacchus and philemon
they have been poor all of their lives
but generous with what little they have
the gods recognize them for their
righteousness and ask what they would
like most in the world
bacchus and philemon ask that when death
draws near they might die together so
that neither shall see the other die nor
be left behind the gods make it so
the old lovers become trees an oak and a
linden which intertwine their branches
with one another as they grow
absent interference from zeus the only
way to avoid grief is to live a life
without love
grief has evolved multiple times across
species always in highly social
organisms with parental care
the grief of chimps is presumably the
same at its root as human grief
the grief of dogs has distinct origins
though as the most recent common
ancestor that we share with dogs was a
nondescript little mammal with little to
no social structure
perhaps the most famous story of how
grief manifests in dogs is that of
hachiko a handsome akita who was born in
japan in 1923.
hachiko was taken in by jerasoburo ueno
a professor of agriculture who commuted
to work by train
every day when ueno was due back hachiko
met him at the train station and they
walked home together
one day awana did not return having died
of a cerebral hemorrhage while lecturing
hachiko however continued to go to the
train station every day
and wait for his master for nearly 10
years until he himself died
the grief of canids wolves and domestic
dogs evolved separately from our own
elephants also grieve as do killer
whales in all of these cases grief is
independently evolved yet deeply similar
an extreme emotional response to the
death of an intimate unpredictable in
its length and manifestation
modern approaches to loss and degree
tend to over emphasize metrics and
logistics
how many years had he been sick how do i
obtain a death certificate close bank
accounts cancel appointments
and spend too little on meaning a
narrative what did he bring to us
how are we better for him having lived
we often don't want to see the body or
sit with it at all
death is a to remove in this particular
hyper novel situation
in which it is our choice to not
confront the corpse of a loved one can
render us more confused in the aftermath
of death
grief is us recalibrating our brains for
a world without one of its central
pieces
we must reformulate our understanding as
we are no longer able to go to that
person
or animal for words of wisdom or comfort
but we are still able to think back
to learn from and to take comfort in the
relationship that can no longer grow but
can still be remembered
we don't want to believe in their
permanent absence and so our brains
create fictions
ghosts was that him turning the corner
at the cafe we used to frequent
surely that was her i know her hair her
jacket getting on the train
grief is the downside of high bandwidth
interdependence
grief is the downside of love all too
often moderns try to protect children
from grief
for instance we have known parents who
would not allow their children to attend
their grandparents funerals for fear
that it would scare them or harm them
this fear and anxiousness in raising
children in turn creates fearful and
anxious children
in the next chapter we explore childhood
and how to raise children who are
independent
exploratory and full of love
and then the very first corrective lens
for this chapter is
now actually the second one spend time
with the body of your loved one after
they die
those who have lost loved ones to
situations from which their bodies could
not be recovered
often suffer from prolonged periods of
grief
when we view our dead sit with them and
talk with them we set a foundation upon
which our grief our natural
recalibration
can be moored
so i mean this this chapter goes has a
ton of stuff in it right it's all over
the place
um but that felt that felt appropriate
given that we recently lost one of our
one of our kitties moxie
as regular viewers and listeners now um
and of course that hadn't happened at
the point that we were writing this
um but i was i was thinking specifically
of
of my father and of your grandfather um
who had you know who who had died within
a decade um of of writing this
and just thinking about
the way that the modern medical
structure moved in and tried to
uh prevent the natural grieving process
in both in both cases
right in the case of my father um
who unfortunately died in the icu um but
surrounded by
five people in the world who who loved
him tremendously
my mother his wife um
and you know who they would have just
celebrated their 53rd wedding
anniversary this last month
uh and you and i are two children um
and the staff at the hospital and the
you know the staff at the hospital were
mostly quite kind
and an understanding but they were um
i think shocked that we wanted to stay
in the room afterwards and we stayed
with his body for an hour or so
um and then also accompanied it
um to the crematorium when it came time
for that
and it it really helped
assure me anyway of what i did not want
to be true
but it assured me that it was true and
it helped me not
be in denial about it any more than
would have been would have been helpful
yeah the ambiguity that one is left with
if
one doesn't have some sort of evidence
that's incontrovertible
is obviously a source of um
of danger psychologically speaking and
uh it is not surprising that we would be
built this way
because you know to put it in relatively
stark terms
human being is a big animal and it's
hard for a human being
to die in um you know your home range
and there to be no evidence so in
general
our ancestors would have had a pretty
good idea you know somebody wouldn't
simply disappear with no sign there'd be
uh awareness in general um and so
lost at sea is particularly hard for
this reason right well and c
is novel that's the thing it's not that
novel but uh
yeah we were coastline explorers for a
long time but not deep deep ocean
voyagers until
relatively recently right i'm not saying
it never happened and i'm not saying
that the evidence was always
um you know really substantial
obviously there are predators in the
world but a predator doesn't tend to
take
out a human being and leave no evidence
and you know
there tends to be uh a record enough
that a person
can grieve and move on which we argue is
you know
is this is the downside of love it's not
that grief is inherently
good but grief is necessary when you
have loved a person or
a creature deeply in order to rewire
so that their absence is not a constant
obstacle to functioning same thing as
you know just as we were talking about
earlier today anxiety and depression
are not inherently maladaptive right you
know some
sometimes the world is such that
depression is the appropriate response
sometimes your situation is such that
anxiety is the appropriate response
you know when someone you love has has
died grief is the appropriate response
can each of those appropriate adaptive
responses
occur in situations or for duration for
instance
that make them maladaptive of course and
um you know but but
the modern quick fix types of solutions
would have you medicate equally all
instantiations
and that that misunderstands
um that there are there are appropriate
times and places for
for all of these responses of course and
in fact
the um the pattern of grief leaves no
doubt whatsoever this is not a
malfunction
right this is a highly organized process
which tells you that
you know it is it is providing a benefit
um and i would say it's a necessity
um you know and it's one of these things
one of the one of the things
features of the pattern is that you can
put off grief
right if you can't you you don't grieve
on the battlefield when your best friend
has just died in front of you
you fight and then you grieve later and
that that capacity to put it off
um but not forever is you know one of
its fascinating features and of course
you would expect that you can't have a
creature who can be suddenly debilitated
by grief so that they themselves succumb
to whatever the threat is that just
wouldn't make sense as a program
so so it isn't like that
but it is also true that we
intervene in this process you know both
by
um you know uh removing bodies and
having a process that deals with them
so that you know the family doesn't have
contact that might
um be part of the closure process
but we also i think this we did not put
this into the
the book but there's this issue of you
know
in our case we did not ask to know
the sex of the children that we were
going to have in one case we found out
accidentally because the technician
uh you know it was pretty rare we
specifically asked not to we asked not
to know
explicitly yeah i took it out of the
book because it was i don't know we
didn't have time to explore it fully
but i will just say that the the
question is this
yeah no it is it's gone i think it's not
there yeah um but
the question is is this if you are going
to have a child
and you do not know its sex in advance
as no ancestor until very recently could
have been certain
what it does is it prevents you from
doing too much scenario building about
what your life is going to look like
after the child is born and what that
means
is that the degree to which you have to
forget
this lesson is um
decreased and that in some sense by now
providing this information which seems
like what could the harm
of more information about you know the
child you're going to have
what could the harm of that possibly be
well the harm could be that once you
know you're going to have a boy or
you're going to have a girl and you
start thinking about
here are the places we'll go this is
what we'll do this is what it'll be like
that there is the need for vastly more
grief to unwire those things
at the point of loss well i guess i mean
i would also
argue that um you know for us
we intended to raise our children
without the expectation
of of stereotypes right and we're not
going to paint a room blue or pink
depending on the sex of the child
um either way right that was just never
never in anything that we were thinking
and um
frankly imagining all the possibilities
absent any overlay
of of of boy or girl male or female
helped help to keep that alive and you
know even though i think that we were
particularly just because of who we are
and how we think and what we think about
uh would have been unlikely to fall prey
to those kinds of stereotypes but
especially in this
in this modern era um
where we should be as free as possible
from
the traditional gender roles that don't
have specific anatomical or
physiological bases
you know what what does it get you
to know in advance if you're going to
have a boy or a girl and you know in
both cases because i was
um because i was older um you know we
had all the genetic testing and so you
know
there was a karyotype and a sealed
envelope in both cases that you know i
could have looked at any moment
since looked at and like sure enough
fair enough that y chromosome in both
cases but um
specifically did not want to know in
advance yeah
um and you know at some level even if
you didn't have
um these two reasons formulated
that you might not want to know the one
thing that you can know for sure
is that the information wouldn't have
been available to an ancestor and so you
don't know whether there's any
you know uh harm downstream of it now of
course
scientifically speaking this makes a
prediction which is that in the case
that somebody
loses uh a pregnancy
that the amount of grief will actually
correlate with
um whether or not they did or didn't
know
and that at some level is something i
think we should be i don't know if it's
been tested but
it is something we should be looking
into because at some level
um the the the natural way of doing this
may simply be
superior and we may be creating
unnatural trauma
um that could you know be avoided if we
just simply realized we were being
unwise
yeah you know i actually remember um a
grad school colleague
how's this been in the 90s i think or
maybe early very early aughts
um who uh he was
a guy but we were also friends with his
uh with his wife who was also a grad
school colleague and and she got
pregnant
um and she never said this um but he
said at the point that they revealed
what the sex of their baby was going to
be i don't even remember what it was
um and i said something to him like
are you sure that that's something that
you wanted to know or i don't know
exactly what i said he said
i'm a scientist more information is
always better
i thought that seems like a rule
that sounds like something you can say
and have most people agree with
but i don't think it's true yeah it's
definitely not it's not true
there are many cases in which more
information tends to be better but there
are certainly cases where more
information can
be destructive yeah exactly
[Music]
you